in the opening scene we are introduced
to an 11-year-old Eli Miller playing
outdoors in the garden under the warm
sunlight suddenly he experiences a
severe bout of coughing and collapses on
the ground visibly struggling to breathe
his skin then becomes red making him cry
out for assistance just then he wakes up
inside a sterile bubble within his room
revealing that it was all just a dream
it turns out that the young boy is
suffering from a rare disease that
causes severe allergic reactions to the
outdoor doors this forces him to live
his life in protective gear but he still
got nothing on Bubble Boy despite the
challenges Eli receives unwavering love
from his mother who tries to express her
affection through the plastic bubble so
that he won't feel lonely we also learn
that the daily items used by Eli need
thorough sterilization and placement in
a bag before washing his clothes come in
airtight bags and he has to wash himself
with wet wipes whenever he travels
outside he has to put on a special
protective Hazmat suit he'd probably get
bullied if he didn't look like such a
badass one day Eli's parents Paul and
Rose take him out of the place as they
seem to have found a place for his
treatment it appears to be a long
journey so they spend a night at a motel
the next morning as they prepare to
leave a group of bullies taunt Eli oh
for wearing the protective suit they
even toss a cracker in his way causing
him to stumble this tears his suit and
he has difficulty breathing but before
anything bad happens his parents heard L
seal the torn suit with duct tape hence
saving his life after an entire day of
driving the family arrives at the
treatment center which turns out to be
an old mansion that has been modernized
and quarantined at first Eli is sent
through a decontamination process
followed by his parents once inside
they're received by Dr horn who's been
using this treatment for years on
various kids despite the doctor's
assurance that it's safe and Eli can
remove his protective suit the boy
remains skeptical as they make their way
to their room Eli curiously asks if she
has saved any other children however the
latter evades the question and simply
promises to make him better just then
they hear an unusual noise coming from
the ceiling which horn attributes to the
air filtration process Eli also spots a
small dark Corridor where he catches a
fleeting glimpse of a girl but she
quickly vanishes when he questions horn
about the area she simply deems it
unsafe for him and proceeds forward she
then leads them to Eli's room and shows
them a bathroom with filtered water the
little boy nervously removes his suit
and to his Delight nothing bad happens
now he's finally able to hug his parents
after years of isolation later Eli takes
a shower shedding tears of joy as he
relishes its sense of normaly as night
falls he struggles to sleep due to
strange noises echoing through his room
soon his attention is drawn to a bug
repeatedly hitting the window he gets up
to check only to see a small foggy patch
res resembling someone's breath moments
later he's startled by a hand print on
the fog which prompts him to run to his
parents' room for the night M dad
there's an invisible pedo sneaking Peaks
out there the following morning horn
leads Eli to the operating room to
initiate the first stage of the
treatment there nurses change his outfit
record his weight and capture some
photographs intrigued by the pictures
Eli questions the nurse but she
playfully warns him against asking
questions after this he is tied to the
table and a special Contraption is used
to hold his head in place making him
nervous horn then begins to explain the
science behind this treatment while
injecting him with some unknown
substances however Eli is distracted by
the creepy reflection he sees on the
back of a chair before he can inquire
about it he is knocked out cold upon
regaining Consciousness Eli experiences
intense pain caused by burning skin he
desperately pleads to be released but to
no avail suddenly he jolts awake in his
room realizing it it was merely a
nightmare he then gets up to look
through the window and sees a girl named
Haley throwing stones she invites him to
meet her and Eli who is eager to connect
rushes downstairs they introduce
themselves and start bonding over their
shared interest in Magic Eli attempts to
demonstrate a card trick but she
surprises him by igniting fire in her
hand that was some David Blain says
Eli he then invites her inside but she
refuses explaining that the place is
creepy after Haley leaves Eli heads back
to his room room in the corridor he
spots a creepy girl causing him to be
startled at the same time the lights go
out and he notices that the girl is
chasing him frightened he tries to run
away but stumbles and Falls as the
lights flicker a spooky Shadow behind a
curtain adds to his fear however he's
relieved to learn that it's just his
father creeping on his ass who scolds
him for wandering alone in the house
during dinner Eli confides his
frightening experiences in his parents
but they don't believe him that night he
reads a magic book to understand the
trick demonstrated by Haley earlier
during this his attention is caught by
an oddly shaped curtain he walks forward
to check but finds no one following this
the boy proceeds to write his name on
the foggy glass to his horror someone
erases the letter e of his name and adds
it at the end turning it in to lie
startled he steps backward only to get
bumped into his wardrobe in its mirror
he sees a reflection of a ghost girl
leaving him truly terrified Eli tries to
crawl away but a hand grabs his legs
prompting him to scream in fear however
he sees that it's his parents trying to
calm him down later they discuss his
experiences with horn and she claims it
to be the side effects of the medication
according to her one needs to get worse
before getting better the next day Eli
undergos the second phase of treatment
once again his hands and legs are
fastened to the bed and additional
devices are attached to his head this
time as horn administers the injection
Eli's skin starts burning causing in him
excruciating pain to his bad luck horen
says that the virus intended to cure him
is unable to breach the bloodbrain
barrier as a result she drills a hole
into his skull causing the boy to lose
Consciousness in agony this movie is
rated R for skull holes later at the
dining table Eli tells his parents that
he feels the doctors are making him
sicker and expresses his wish to leave
but this only makes Paul angry so he
gives Eli an ultimatum to stay in get
better or leave and remain sick forever
eventually the boy changes his mind
agreeing to stay and continue the
treatment the same night he hears a
noise coming from the bathroom prompting
him to investigate he sees a shadow
behind the shower curtain but when he
pushes them aside there's nothing while
closing the tap on the sink he spots
another scary figure in the mirror
startled he tries to run away but the
door is locked this forces him to hide
inside a wardrobe the ghost then
shatters the mirror and begins shaking
the Wardrobe when the boy doesn't come
out it pushes the Wardrobe to the floor
before disappearing a while later Eli
finally steps out and discovers the word
lie inscribed repeatedly into the
Wardrobe door what is Eli lying about
could it be that he doesn't actually
like magic hearing the commotion Rose
Paul and Horn enter the room and think
that Eli broke the furniture they then
set him down to discuss what's troubling
him Eli tries to explain what he's
experiencing but no one believes him
later on he meets Haley and confides in
her about the haunting feeling in the
mansion in response she tells him about
a previous patient Perry who also had
similar experiences did Perry get better
asks Eli no he died just kidding however
she never saw him again after the third
stage of his treatment Haley then
strongly urges Eli to leave the place
before the third stage of treatment but
he explains that survival in the outside
atmosphere is not an option suddenly the
lights inside the house begin to flicker
seeing this Eli asks Haley to wait and
goes to check moments later some strange
forces push him to the ground and begin
dragging him to the decontamination door
as he screams he sees that he's being
pulled by three ghosts probably previous
patients the ghosts also open the main
door triggering a negative reaction in
his body thankfully his parents and Horn
arrive just in time to rescue him Eli
then accuses Horn of killing Perry with
her treatment but she refuses to
acknowledge Him in the midst of the
chaos the boy accidentally hits his arm
on the fire alarm this causes him to
bleed and he eventually passes out upon
regaining Consciousness he overhears
horn discussing his condition with his
parents she admits that the treatment
isn't producing the desired effects and
advises them to convince their son to
continue taking medicines on time
following this Eli's mother goes to his
room to give him the medicine which she
politely puts in his mouth seeing this
his mother gives him a consoling hug
during this he suddenly notices the
scrap scatches made by the ghost on the
Wardrobe and realizes that it isn't a
word but some numbers written upside
down after his mother leaves he spits
out the medicine revealing that he
didn't ingest it meanwhile horn Burns
Eli's suit in an effort to stop him from
escaping in his next meeting with Haley
Eli recounts his ghostly encounters as
well as the discovery that the word lie
is actually the inverted number 317 as
they discuss Haley speculates that the
number might be a code for a door later
at midnight Eli sneaks out of his room
and uses the same passcode to access the
Forbidden room meanwhile Rose gets into
an argument with her husband because he
had been hiding a fact Eli's survival
after the treatment is actually
uncertain Rose who isn't ready to lose
her child decides to leave the place and
begins loading their stuff in the car
but horn intervenes and manages to
convince her to stay asserting that
there is still hope back at the
Forbidden room Eli finds the treatment
file of the last three patients Perry
Agnes and Lucius all of whom perished
during the third stage of treatment
shocked he rushes to inform his parents
about this however he only finds his
father and confides in him Paul pretends
to listen calmly and hugs him for
Comfort however it turns out to be a
trap as he deceitfully injects him with
an anesthetic even though the drug
doesn't work the nurses come to take the
protesting Eli to the operating room on
the way the boy bites one of the nurses
and shoves the other away freeing
himself he then runs to the Forbidden
room to retrieve the files but learns
that the nurses have hidden everything
desperate Eli seizes a knife from the
table to threaten them and escapes into
Horn's room there he finds a photograph
that reveals that horn and her nurses
are all nuns right then a bug appears
and guides him to a secret door in the
room upon opening it he finds creepy
stairs leading to an underground chamber
it houses a small Christian Shrine and a
lid Ed pit suddenly the door closes from
behind and Eli realizes that his parents
and Horn have locked him inside in an
attempt to Shield himself from the
atmospheric reaction Eli covers his
mouth with his clothes but his efforts
prove futile his face eventually turns
red causing him to collapse on the
ground however after taking a few deep
breaths his skin reverts to normal which
finally makes him realized that his
illness has always been a lie on the
other hand horn and the nurses prepare
the operating room to carry out the
third phase of the treatment a short
while later Rose hears her son crying
and decides to check on him however it
turns out to be a ploy as the boy
strikes her and fleases the scene he
heads to a room with a large glass
window and tries to break it with a fire
extinguisher for an escape sadly the
window is unbreakable unlike the windows
of a cyber truck and Paul apprehends him
with the help of the nurses they then
take him to the operating room back in
the underground bunker Rose stumbled
upon a cross containing a dagger she
also checks the pit and Witnesses a
gruesome sight the rotten bodies of the
previous patience finally realizing that
her son was right she rushes to the
operating room and threatens horn with
the dagger however Paul intervenes and
calms her down assuring her that he'll
help her he manages to take the dagger
from her hand and unexpectedly hands it
over to Horn it's pretty expected if you
ask me sensing the Betrayal Rose panics
but Paul holds her back and the ritual
begins horn pours holy water on Eli
triggering a severe skin reaction she
then grabs the dagger and proceeds to
stab him but an unseen Force stops her
from doing so turns out that it's Eli
using his telepathic Powers what he
turns the dagger around and kills horn
instead then he lights the bindings on
fire and frees himself from captivity
with his skin glowing red the boy goes
through a full demonic transformation
using his powers he makes the Nurses
Float around him and burns them alive
following this Eli confronts Rose
seeking the truth about his identity she
finally reveals that she couldn't have
children no matter how much she prayed
desperate to be a mother she turned to
Satan he eventually granted her a baby
but it wasn't normal as a result she had
been trying everything possible to make
him normal amidst their conversation
Paul advances with the sacrificial
dagger but Eli kills him by crushing his
face
telekinetically you Dad after
spreading the fire through the mansion
with a mere Touch of his feet Eli goes
outside and the fresh air helps him put
the transformation away he also finds
Haley who explains that she as well as
all the dead patients are also Children
Of Satan she further admits that she was
unable to tell him because he had to
find and prove his own strength in order
to earn his place she then offers to
take Eli to his biological father when
he accepts Haley wonders if Eli can
trust his mother in response he accepts
the coat that Rose offers indicating
that he can the movie ends with rose
driving the two children away from the
burning facility subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching